well hello everyone welcome to today's
live broadcast fish welfare stress
pathology handling and managing I am
Marcel Pento and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we have a few
announcements to make before we get
started this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
as many questions you as you want to H
you can submit your questions by typing
them in the Q&A box which can be found
by clicking on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window we'll try to answer all the
questions that we can you can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon and the lower right hand
corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A lower
button on the lower
left I would like to introduce today's
speaker Dr Juan r
Dr Ramos Is the aquatic animal
supervisor at the Barcelona biomedical
research park for the past year he has
been setting out the cry preservation
service for zebra fish sperm at the
prbb I will now turn it over to Dr Ramos
for his presentation Dr Ramos thank you
very much for agreeing to this
presentation I will pass the
presentation to
you hello
everybody H good afternoon from from
Barcelona I will try to explain with
this presentation different items that
are related with with fish welfare so
for that I divided my presentation in
four main parts the first of all is is
going to explain which what is a fish
and what are the main difference between
fish and mammals which kind of
requirements do they need to their
maintenance afterwards we are going to
talk just a little bit about what we
call a welfare or mal that is related
with stress and pathology and finally we
we have like an example of working with
fish and taking care of them that is the
thra fish that as you will know is the
star of of the fish
research
so we are working with f and nowadays
the people is taking more concent about
H what is going on with with animals and
the beams so the Fe are not an exception
about that so the society H wants to to
keep their animals better so also in
their research the law is always falling
following
the the people and the society so the
last European law takes in account the
the f as a animal research and also
include the first invertebrate as an
animal research that is the
octopus so when we think in fish
research most of you can think in in
what we know as fish uh research with
bio research that mainly is the thra Fe
and other species like the balloon fish
or maybe the goopy or the metaka are
using are used also in BIO research but
there is another huge field that is the
the aquaculture items or that are
related with the fish in Spain we are a
power in in fish research in aquaculture
items so we we can have many many
facilities that are working with with
this species so this facility must must
has a lot of a lot of tanks and must be
AED to many many kind of
fces so first of all we we must Define
what is
welfare and you can find out that there
are many many definitions going
around uh but I choose this one that is
for the farm animal welfare commit that
is located in United
Kingdom and mainly it says that it must
be freedom for different things freedom
from hunger and thirst H freedom for
discomfort from Pain and injury and
freedom to spread their normal behavior
also there must be Freedom or we must
avoid what we what I called the UN
welfare but if you think in in Fe this
definition is not directly translate to
them so we must collap
them if we are working with fish as
Isabel Market said the worst thing for a
fish is treating them like human that
means that we have to change our point
of view or and also our our knowledge
about taking care of animals because
they are more interested in other things
and they need other things than the
mamals or other
vertebrates so first of all we have to
take in account that the fish are
aquatic animals so we have to take care
about the
water the water quality is really
important but also the the dyamics the
way that is going to to flow the water
around the tank and and around the life
support
system also the tank will have a lot of
importance a great importance because it
will allow the fish to have the normal
behavior and also it will handle more
more than one fish so we we can set
different kind of densities or
populations also we we should take care
about the diet and the food that we are
going to to give to our animals and the
way that we are going to handle them of
course we should avoid uh all items
related with un welfare so we have to
know which kind of things are are making
our Fe
stressed also we can we we have a a
biography review but we have to take in
account also the requirements made by
low H I will explain my my point of view
that is from Spain Europe so in in
Europe we have a new almost a new law
for research with animals and this is
the transposition for the Spanish low I
will translate to you but it say
something that like that the this will
be fine so nothing particular you must
give the proper water the proper oxin
the water
temperature these kind of things but
nothing is really is really on the tile
and we can think that this kind of low
has no sense but it has a lot of sense
but we are because we are talking about
fish so what happen with fish fish H are
a huge group of animals that has more
diversity than the other vertebrates so
if we can think in in a kind of living
the fish will have this so we have
different adaptation for for theology so
we can find things that are lonely
garous territorial bagic bonic unisexual
arrod with G respiration with cutanous
respiration with external reproduction
with internal W so most of of the the
way of living they will be adapted to so
if we are working with fees we can just
say fees so we must specify which kind
of speci are we working with so after we
know which kind of speci are we working
with we must make a biography review and
find out which kind of uh parameters or
recommendations are set up also we can
go to the aquaculture techniques or the
public aquarium ones
that should have a lot of information
about taking care of the animals of or
fish we should avoid uh all kind of
Disney referees or a human way of
thinking and translate our our brain to
a f
mode uh we we don't have to go in panic
because of course the the fish has a
common
characteristics they most mostly of them
are dermic so they are cold blooded so
this means that their metabolism rate
will be directly on relation with the
water
temperature also the limbs are modified
in FS so they they can swim in the water
the skin will be covered by by scales as
an armor and this will protect against
different
things the skeleton is made by bone or
ctil and the respiration will be made by
GS they have a a simple circulation and
complete that means that the heart will
push the the blood from from the heart
to the GS and afterwards to the to the
body there is not going to be a double
circulation as the mammals also the
reproduction will be stal excepting the
the Sharks and other cus fish so when we
are thinking in fish we have to think in
this kind of animals that includes the
ja group that are the mixin and the L
the carus fish that are the shars the
chimeras and the Ray and also the Boni
fish that are the most common one as the
Moon Moon Fish or the cbra fish or also
the Abal
fish so when we look to to the fish we
can see that they have many saves and
these shapes are aded to the way of of
swimming so the limbs will be also
related about that also the mouth and
the teeth will will be aded to their
ecology and the way of eating so we can
find many kinds of mouths in different
positions and with different kind of of
teeth also we can find an special
sensory system that is presented in
aquatic animals especially in in fish
that is the lateral Line This lateral
line we can see a like a line going
along the the body of the fish that is
made by by points this lateral line uh
will have will act as as a r like like
the B one but in a passive way that
means that they are not going to make a
noise and catch it they are going just
to catch the movements of the of the
water so we have to take in account the
sensor assistant because uh if we are
going to to fish them with an N which
will make a slow of movements so they
will not interpretate this as a an as
attack for them also they have a
swimming bladder that is going to allow
them to move along the water column
going up and down without spending
energy H also the skin is is really
different from other M for other animals
and it has many parts H the skin will
act as a a barrier against chemical and
theolog agents and also will helps for
Theo regulation of the
fish it will have also electric orans
and potion glands H the mucus that is
over the skin will helps for the hamic
because it will decrease the the the the
force that are between the the water the
friction that is between the water and
the and the body so this scheme is
divided in many parts the first part the
external one will be the cuticle that is
specializ side in in a in a monologic
function and we have a lot of compounds
for
that H below that we can find the the
epidermis that is going to be special
side in secreting mucus this mucus will
act as a proper barrier and also will
have for the euramic so decreasing the
friction of the water and the
body H also inside of this mcus we can
find out some some immunologic cells as
the lympocytes and the
macrofagos beneath the epidermis we will
find the vasal membrane that is dividing
the epidermis and the dermis the dermis
that is under under it uh will have the
the function of secreting the scale and
giving the support for the rest of the
skin the scales are calcific seeds that
are disposed from cranial to
Cal in a cranial from to Cal way and
there are overlapping so we have to take
in account uh the special skin if we are
going to handle the fish because we can
remove this mucus that is really handful
harmful for them and also remove the the
scales so we have to take in account
this and try to use wet materials glovs
and also the proper
net so also it's important to consider
different physiology functions as the
respiration that is going to work uh
differently from from the other
vertebrates as you will know that the
fish are inside of the water and they
will pick the the air from or the o from
the from the
water the water will have less oxygen
and is more discos and more dense than
the than they are so they have an an
specialized organ that is the GS that
are like faral bags four far four PIR
pairs of faral bags that are
disposed um in the last part of the oral
car these gen we have to to anys and
these Ms will have the filaments that
are the functional part of the G so the
filament will will release the CO2 and
will catch the the oxygen from the Water
by the fusion H they are disposed in
crosscurrent way so uh they will have
more time to do this dys function also
in the Gs we can find another kind of
cells that are not related with the
respiration that are more related with
the osmo regulation there that are the
ionides these ionides are are specializ
side in making the
transport also to protect the the G from
from different kind of water H we have
the mucus cells that protects the
filament from the from the
water uh the way that the fish is going
to be related with the with the water it
has a lot of implication about the
regulation the regulation is the way
that the animal is going to keep the
ionic balance inside of the cell against
the the natural tendance of of of of
this kind of problems that will equalize
the this difference of ionic
pressure so if we think in F we can
think think in fresh water and salt
water we're going to focus in in the
fresh waterer ones
these these FS will have more ionic
concentration I concentration inside of
the cells than the
water so H they the natural tendance is
going to release some ions from from the
cell and catch some water so the the
fish will fight against this H just
putting a lot of water outside of his
body making a d urine and also uh ing
the ions from the from the blood and
from the water using their kidneys and
the GS if we think in the other hand if
we think in the saltwater F it's going
to be the opposite so summarizing this
osmo
regulation we can say that they are
going to drink like a like a
fish so to keep our our Fe fine we will
have a a proper facility these these
aquatic animals have a great dependence
of the media and changing the am will
act directly on the physiological state
of them so these special facilities the
life support system are specialized to
keep as constant and as better the water
quality I usually compare these kind of
these facilities with with a body the
first part will be the the phas what are
we watching every day H what are we
interacting with it that is the tank
this tank uh will have a lot of
importance because it will handle the Fe
and allows him to make the natural
behavior in the body we have a a blood
stream that is going to flow around the
the body so this is this will be related
with the water solce the water is going
to flow along the pipes that will be our
veins and flows directly to the to the
heart the heart will be the pump of the
life support system so this pump will
push the blood or the water around the
system this blood will have H some
particles that we have to to remove from
it as the kidney that are the mech
mechanical filters and also we have some
toxic comp compounds that will could be
H processed and decrease this toxicity
this will be the biological filter in
the light support system as our Li
does also to kill the bad guys that are
going around or water we have an
immunologic system uh that will be
almost like the ocean of the UV or the
chemical filtration the chemical
filtration is going to be almost all the
the time the chakal filter that will
remove some toxic compounds if we have
some problems with our heart we can set
up some Pac makers that will be
automatizing or some kind of proofs that
are going to send us a lot of
information and let us know what is
going on in our
system so right now we have h a lot of
done we have our speci we have our our
life support system design but we we
don't have a steel or water inside of it
so we have to decide which kind of water
are we going working with and also
Define the paramet the parameters that
we should control depending on the spe
and the final OB of the research we
should h
control more or less parameters I
usually uh divide the parameters in two
kind of groups the first one the
physical one because we measure them
with proofs and these ones are the
temperature the salinity the oygen and
the pH we measure these these parameters
every day because they are easy to to
measure and really fast and the other
kind of parameters are the chemical ones
that we are going to measure with with
colometric test and this will could be
for example the alkalinity the hardness
the calcium the ammonia different NR
compounds the chorine the copper and
many
more so we have to Define our parameters
and we should know that these parameters
are not going to be stable all the time
they are going to move uh and we expect
that this movement will be almost the
same so I make this table that is
summarizing this kind of things that is
going to happen in our life support
system with the water quality and for
example I will explain the pH that that
that is a value that is going to be
decreased about the respiration that is
happening in our in our water in our
water we have a lot of respiration rate
not just the fish ones we have a lot of
bacterias inside of of of water and
these bacterias are mainly located in
the bio filter so this this respiration
is going to pick oxygen from the water
and release ci2 C2 in the water will
react as a acid Carbonic so the pH will
be decreased to avoid this we should put
some buffer inside of the water so we
increase a little bit the ph and also
the
alkalinity H going back to the bacterias
that are making the respiration these
bacterias are located in the biofilter
and are responsible of making the
nitrogen cycle that is going to decrease
a lot the nitrogen the toxicity of the
nitrogen compounds so these nitrogen
compounds will be the ammonia nitrate
and nitrite and the nitrite will be
accumulative so we have to remove it h
throwing out the the water from our
facility so we have our life support
system and the water is running out but
we have to put inside our fish we still
don't know how how many and how much Fe
can we put uh inside of the life support
system or in the T So for that we have
to define the maintenance density and
it's quite hard to Define in a general
way because we have to take in account
many things first of all we have to take
in account uh which kind of light
support system are we going to have
which kind of filtration because the
filtration is going to handle a concrete
uh number of fish or amount of fish so
the if we put too many fish the water
quality is going to be decreased really
really
fast so it's hard to to define the the
water quality and about this and also
about the species that we are going to
use if we have H for example tbot they
are going to be more interested in the
surface or if we we have a really
swimming fish we we will use more the
the volume so depending in these kind of
things we should h define the the
density of the animals that we are going
to have inside also we can variate a
little bit of we can modify this density
by using this kind of refugees or having
anous size of of
density or or F sorry and using more
tricks so um the is really important to
be defined first of all because it has
economical importance this is not
related with Animal Welfare it's just
with boss welfare so let's move to the
other importance that this is
theological one theological implication
will be really great because uh some
fish are used to have a High densities
as seals and other ones prefer to be
more lonely in the tank so depending the
spey we should choose different
densities and this density will affect
to theological way of acting so it will
uh determinate the hierarchy and will
increase this this kind of H problems
and also we we can see different
variations of the way of of swimming
also the the feeding rate the growing
rates or the reproduction ones this kind
of affections will be will be measured H
with with the
cortisol so we have our fees inside of
the tank and we have to feed them but we
don't know we still don't know which
kind of food and which kind of amount or
which amount should we use so we should
know that the the fish or the Aquatic
animals need less calories than the than
other vertebrates because they don't use
energy to control h they don't use the
energy to control the temperature they
also H need less energy to move around
the water and also to secrate the the
ammonia instead the uric acid or the
Ura in the other hand the they are used
to have a protein metabolism that means
that they don't like to eat pasta or
rice they prefer to eat T-Bones or
chicken for for
example so they are adapted to many ways
of of eating so we must adapt our our
way of feeding to the way of eating also
the kind of food that we are going to
give them should be
adapted they have they usually have a
indirect development so we should choose
in the right moment the proper food and
the proper way of feeding
them there are also white animals some
some kind of species or fishes are going
to
be less less less hungry so we have to
increase this level of hungry just
making some treats putting putting life
food inside of the tanks or maybe using
tasty tasty flavors for them
as we said before there are called clo
animals so the metabolism is going to be
affected by the
temperature as you can see in the table
the fish need like twice times the
protein than a chicken or three times
than a
cow so yes summarizing this kind of H
nutrition issues we have to take in
account that the feeding rate will be
determinated by different factors we
have endogenous factor that are related
with the fish as the species the age of
or development States the physiological
States or the genetics and in the other
hand uh we have H sub factors that are
more related with the ambient as the
water temperature or the season or just
related with the with the proper food as
the composition the size of the pellet
the amount of the food food or the
frequency that we are giving this
food so right now everything is going
right we have our fish inside of our
water we are feeding them but we we
think that we can improve a little bit
the welfare so we are thinking in using
enrichement for them first of all the
enrichement should be useful and not get
lost in doing strange things like like
this paper that shows there is effect
between mosa music and the physiology
with of
thio maybe they have used bin or queen
they find out some kind of relation but
I think it has no really sense so the
enrichement H soon decrease or helps the
fist H to get used to the facility and
reduce the the
stress also has to increase of will
increase the inter specific or or
intraspecific relations so they will be
much much
better H as en reement we can use like
food that is really useful in in fish or
use other kinds of enement at refugees
substrates H Sal Nets or plants they
should be easy to clean and they don't
have to interfere in the experimental
procedure
so yes keeping in the fish way we have
to forget the toys animals toys and the
Ms and reement we have to use the the
fish
watch so to we are we have our our happy
Fe inside the facility but we have to
make a a procedure so we have to handle
the fish and and we don't know how to
handle so first of all the most
important thing is avoid handling them
okay but I have to handle because I have
to make my procedure so afterwards we we
have to touch him we have to fiz them
with the slow movements of the net
because they have the lateral line we
have to avoid removing the mcus or the
scales so we have to use a proper net
use gloves also we have to use a w
Materials that aoid ER drying the fish
and removing the mucus and also uh
decrease the level of deshydratation how
we can cover the fish with a a a wet
paper or something like that that avoids
the the fish getting getting
dry also if we have to to change the the
fish from one water to another which
will aate them so the the physiology
will be adapted to the new conditions of
the water
water if the fish has to be in a static
tanks without flow we should avoid
feeding them because they are going to
secrate ammonia and the water quality is
going to be decreased really fast also
we should know that vibrations and noise
are really harmful for Fe and they
really get a stress about
that so if we get that the stress f we
will know what which kind of actions are
making this Fe stress a stress Fe is not
a happy feish so it's not a welfare is
not really well so it's mainly the on
welfare
sh so take in account we have a stress
factor as the water quality so we have
to take care of our water quality and
also we have another kind of factors as
the physical ones like handle handle
them improperly
H making transports having too much life
H having noise or a lot of movements
inside the facility and another kind of
factors that could stress or F will be
the biological ones when I mean
biological ones we can see we can think
in what are the pathogens okay and also
the interations between the fish and
other
fish also the if we have a lot of
particles flowing our water they will
stress our
fish so if we got a stress fish we have
to decrease their stress and we have
many tricks uh to to do that first of
all is avoiding them getting stress so
we are we are going to to avoid fishing
them if we have to to fish them we are
going to make
properly also we can decrease a little
bit the light so they might get more
quiet then we can also decrease the
levels of of oxygen we can use refugees
and other kind of
enrichment another kind of of trick is
decreasing the water stress the water
stress is the energy that the the fish
needs to keep their OS osmo
regulation so if we get this this
difference between the cell osmotic
pressure and the watermatic pressure
closer we are going to decrease the
energy that he needs to to keep this
balance so uh summarizing this is if we
have a fresh waterer fish we can
increase a little bit the amount of salt
in the water so the the fish will be
much much
better also if we have to make H
different kind of procedures we can use
anesthetics but right now we don't know
if they are
really fine or they can make different
kind of aggressions for the F so we have
to to take notice of this and also use
the anesthesic only when we
need avoid also the vibrations and noise
and another thing we we should use is
theer the imer is the things that you
can measure by eye and you can't explain
this is usually when you work with f you
should know that if I make this the f
are better or not I can't explain but I
know it so this is for me the IM meter
and we are really used to to use this
this IM
meter another thing is depending on the
species some kind of tricks will act
much better and other ones will will be
washed so you must know your your animal
and your
species so we have to make our procedure
and sometimes the procedure can make
pain to the to the fish we know that the
f can feel pain because they have a
brain structure similar to to us and
also they have an Ur
system they can express in different
ways that they don't feel fine so they
can have anorexia or block the
reproduction function or get darker or
get out of from the
so H the problem is that they can face
in as as the mammals and they canot
vocalize so the level of empathy with
them is going to
be lower than with other animals so just
keep in mind that we have to change uh
our mentality and try to think in in a f
way they can also learn and modify the
behavior so H they can predict the
painful stimuli and avoid
them but we have a real problem with
with the pain in fish
because we are not sure which way which
kind of path are they working with and
exactly how is work in the anales
products of fish usually to test the
analia in
fish the AIC test has been used but it's
just about the
chemical
noors so some protocols with analgesic
products has been set up nowadays but we
still don't know if they are really
useful or how useful are
they we we know for sure that the
morphin is is active and has
analystic function but we have to give
like 30 times that than than the
mamals so
to in in another way just going on with
analisia we assume in F that if we get
them anesthesia they are going to have
an aesia in other kind of animals this
is forbidden but in fish we have almost
no chance so to give an anesthesia to to
fish we can choose between two kinds of
two main kinds of anesthetics but mainly
we are going to use like the breathing
anesthesia we are going to put the
anesthesia inside of the water and if
this anesthesia has to be really long we
we can use this kind of anesthesia
machines that are going to deliver the
anesthesic and the oxygen to the oral
cavity of the fish by a tooth we can
check the the stage of anesthesia by
checking the operan movements and also
remember if we are going to keep the the
fish along long time outside of the
water we should avoid this
rotation
so if we get a stress Fe we should have
diseases with uh we have sick an animals
and we should know which kind of
pathology do we have we have different
ethology of the pathology not just the
pathogens that we are used to to think
always in that the parasites the
bacteria the vus and the fungus we can
have also problems of of with lot low
water quality that means that this is
going not to be the proper ambient so
the f is going to be really stressed and
has real problems also we have to take
in account that the way that we are
going to handle and just H the husbandry
that they are going to have is going to
be related with different kind of
diseases so we will avoid these diseases
and control our our health the status of
the facility just making a proper design
of the facilities we should have
quarantine so we can reach have new
animals and isolate them isolate the
sick animals also we should have a
facility that is to clean and to
disinfect like also the the floor and
the the light support system which will
have a proper uh U and ocean uh
Dimension we have Al we can also modify
our routines to control much better the
quality of of the health status so we
should reduce the movement of the people
who is in contact with the animals we
should disinfect all the material clean
and remove all the waste that is present
in the tanks isolate the sick
animals and these kind of things that
helps us to control the the health
status we shall we should have also a
big control of of the food and the water
that is going around the
facility so if we have sick animals we
can check we can check different
different things not just uh not just uh
asking them or checking the health
status just by a by ey we can know what
is going around in our facility so we
are used to use these kind of tables
that summarize the the problems that the
fish has so we have to check the the
swimming the how they swim the
respiration rate the scales the fs the
eyes the feeding rates also the
reproduction so these kind of things are
really useful for for for for your
facility so we have like a big there
that we must take in account to work
with fish so we are going just again an
example with the start of the fish
research that this is the fish for
example imagine that you are called to
work in a new facility and to work with
theist and you have never worked with a
theist so you get in panic and you say
the what is that so you have to check
and look for what the referees are in in
the in the world so you have to check
different aspects as the biological
requirements the water parameters the
food
which kind of type how amount the amount
the frequency which kind of density are
we going to have the flow of them the
reading method the cross contamination
to keep our facility fine these kind of
things that we we don't
know so we should have a biblography
review and we find that we have a lot of
information about sever fees and some
papers are contradictory between between
them so we have to choose CH some some
referees but we have nowadays some
guidelines that that makes these kind of
things much easier so the guidelines are
really useful and says what to do in
different aspects of taking care of your
Fe so finally you get a proper idea that
what is what are the requirements of for
a fe for your theis so you get a lot of
information that you have to uh to put
in practice in your
facility
so you should have your proper design of
the facility the nowadays we have the
light support system for the are made
with different brands by different
companies and usually there are almost a
standard but you have to take in account
different aspects or or of the facility
not just the life support system you
have to to to think what is going on if
you have no no power or different kind
of energy
plants so in our case we have double
pumps in case that one bro we we can
check CH change really fast to another
one we have also a technical support
that is 24 hours 7 days per week and we
have also a security guards that they're
going around our facility during the
night and checking the points that are
shown in the map so they check really
easily and if there is something going
wrong they will call us also H if
everything goes really really really
really bad we have set a density that
allows us not to have flow during 24
hours and they the fish will have no
problems about
oxygen so you can find many many
examples of facilities this is one this
is the the th one that is like the most
uh the most uh knowledge H
facility but going keeping going on we
we have to decide different aspects of
how are going to handle our Fe so going
to the density we have many reference
about density we have no reference with
the law but we are for example as we are
accredited by the
so we have recommendation of of the alak
or we have other other kinds of
recommendations so in our case we we
decide to make different test just to
check which was uh which one was the
best density finally we we decide to
have around 25 Fe ad Fe in in a 3 lit T
so almost like eight F per liter
something like that that that will be
increase a little
bit H if you standard ize your densities
it will helps you to to fit them
properly and in homogeneous way also uh
the densities will will have to be set
up to give enough space to to grow well
the
fish also you have to take in account
that the if you have high density you
will need more water flow so you have to
regulate this kind of things
remember that the fish the thra fish is
a quiet fish that likes to be in quiet
water so he he doesn't lik really really
high
flows also you have to Define which kind
of fish are going to be in the tank is
there are going to be all males or that
we are going to mix the the
genders H in our case we we have
centralized all the Newan hat tanks so
these tanks has a proper a different
density and need more control than than
the adult ones so this way we we have
more more control of the tanks to know
which kind of tank do we have we are
using different kind of
stickers so these are examples of which
kind of Trials do we have done to set up
different kind of husbandry
items so yes going on with the reading
method H we are going to use the
bleaching protocol to eliminate the
external
pathogens uh
this bleaching method is really useful
for this kind of pathogens but not for
the vertical ones so maybe we should
find new disinfectant metals and control
the the quality of the eggs when they
the X hatch we have to evaluate our
lares to avoid the the short price with
them so we choose the the stri
ones H we are going to put this this Lis
in a petd with natural water we don't
have fungus problems so we avoid using
embryo
media H when the the Laris has like H
six days or seven days we are going to
put in in a regular tank with a drop by
drop flow and we are going to to put H
some tiny powder h on the surface that
is made by
spirulina so this spirulina will be
almost uh all the time there and this
way the the laries are going to eat
almost all the time as soon as possible
we are going to change this way of
feeding to the aremia that is more more
energetic and allows to grow
faster when they are growing we are
going to increase a little bit the the
flow so they are going to be almost
related with the development
stage so here is like a summarize of
what we are doing with with our feeding
protocols so we have different menus
here as you can see we have the
different stickers that are going to say
which kind of menu is going to be the
therapies so we are starting with with
the this tiny Powder made by spirulina
afterwards we are going to move to
aremia that as soon as possible we are
going to change to dry food uh the first
stage of dry food will be especially
energetic and they are different from
the other
ones uh when meanwhile they are
developing we are going to change the
food to a bigger size and afterwards to
the other ones so this way we are going
to to change to adapt our way of feeding
and the way and the food the kind of
food to the development of the
febra we have also an an special sticker
that is what we call happy feast that is
an extra an extra uh a Meal made usually
of frozen food that increase the
reproduction rates so if we have fish
that are under reproduction we are going
to have this H romantic food in the
morning at the end of the day all the
fish will will eat aremia because they
love and it's a kind of enrichment and
also improves the the reproduction rates
we should take in account that we are in
in in a really humidy lab so we have to
keep our food really
dry we are using the the
aremia just like food and also
asement this aremia is is really high
puas and euas concentration so it will
helps to increase the reproduction
rate uh remember that we have the the
Happy Fish sticker that will increase
the the amount of of pffas and Yas that
we are giving to our to office we have a
protocol for for aremia and we have an
special facility and tank uh to to grow
up this
one so us see light food is really a
good thing because you have happy fees
but it's
also a bad point because we can
introduce some B inside of facility so
we have to know that for example parthum
can increase the transmission and
effectivity of mob bacterium and in the
other hand for example for example the
tux that is a frozen food could have so
so capillaria X that has that causes a
lot of problems in our
facilities so to keep our facility fine
and avoid uh contaminations we should
design them properly we and we should
design our routings too so yes
summarizing what what we are doing our
facility we are controlling the access
by card and using a specific cloths so
the people that's going inside has to
remove or to put a a special clo so it
will decrease the amount of people that
is going inside your
facility also we are labeling all the ma
material and each each system has a
proper color and each material is going
to be marked for each system so we avoid
this way crushing in all the materials
and it will be much easier to control
these kind of
things also pre working with with the F
we are going to disinfect our hands with
a alcohol soap that has a high
Spectrum also we are going to pass to a
food bath that is going to infect to
disinfect our our our
shoes we are using a separate quarantine
that allows us to H isolate six animals
and also to re uh the new
animals uh we have to take in account
that in aquatic animals we have a a
natural barrier that is the I water and
that mean that the pathogens can go
through this barrier except the fungus
but if they go through they get inside
of the water the water is going to act
not as a barrier it's going to act as a
vector so remember if you put your
pathogen inside you are going to have
many many
problems so if you have problems you
have to check your health status and
avoid ER having more infection and
trying to remove this these pathogens
from your facility so you can have
different controls make uh certificates
use PCR tools or just trying to make a
history of the of the strain or the
different facilities that you have
received new
animals so it's really important in the
theist facility to have a high
reprodution rate so you should improve
your reproduction or your Crossing
methods so you reduce all the
manipulation and all the injuries that
you are making to your feish when
meanwhile you are catching we are trying
to design like as an automatic recollect
for X so we should avoid fishing them
and manipulating them so we will also
reduce the the work for us and for the
the cleaning
area so this we this way we will have
the same amount of X but much more much
less uh
work also another way of improving the
welfare is going to be making reducing
the number of animals and you can reduce
the number of animals just freezing the
the sperm of them so you can handle much
better the high number of of strains
that you have in your
facility uh we are setting up this this
protocol and the main thing is that you
don't need a big infrastru to you just
need liquid nitrogen dry eyes and a
magnificent glass you will need a
partner to work with and always do it in
the mornings because it's related with
the reproduction in
therapist also you can use anesthetics
as we said before and right now we are
thinking in using another kind of
anesthesic because there are many papers
that say that the Trine that is the most
commonly anesthesic us it in CRA is
really aive for for
animals so we have many kinds of
anesthestic and we are going to try them
and just check if they work better than
the three or
not finally we can think that we have
everything done but the there are more
animals going around our facility these
animals are humans and are really rated
with Animal
Welfare first of all we have the
technician that is the people who is
every day in contact with the animals so
we must train them and Define the SCS
that they should check for animal and
Welfare so it's really important to have
a fluent communication with them and to
make some H Health Report
uh to know which kind of problems do you
have in your facility also on the other
hand you have the researches that
sometimes are not sensible to animals
and sometimes they are not properly
training for working with them so you
have to train in them and if it doesn't
works you can always go to the low and
punish punish
them so I hope you find out this
presentation useful and we help you or
to work better with f or just know a
little more about F and I would like to
give thanks to all of you for paying
attention H to all the Animal Facility
staff of the
prbb especially for The Aquatic ones by
getting wet with me to to toas Garcia by
getting dirty with me and to sitoos to
teaching me to swim so best wishes for
all and many thanks to all of you
byebye okay okay uh well thank you very
much uh ju for that informative
presentation and I particular like the
misspelling at the end on your last
slide on um best
fishes uh that was pretty original so
that was great before we get started on
the Q&A session I would like to remind
our audience how to submit questions you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can so our first
question
is um let's
see okay the first question comes from
Patricia Alderson from Lakehead
University what are some good examples
of enrichment for finfish species
the
examples uh you can use many way of
rement depending on the species you can
use plants that will be set at the
surface you can set plants at the bottom
of the tank you can leave like pipe
tubes uh in SE we are not used to to use
this kind of
enement We Are is just to to have a
proper handling of the population and to
give them a tasty food and to develop
the the way of um attacking other
animals with aremia and these kind of
things but for soul Feast usually we
don't use this kind of enrichment it's
more for lonely
animals
the next question comes from Dr Dan
rothen from the University of Miami by
the way Dan rothin is an expert on fish
is really up and cominging expert on the
in the field and anyone who wants to
talk to him in particular his last name
is spelled r o TSN Thomas h e n Dan ran
from University of Miami feel free to
contact him I have used him in the past
and I have asked him questions that he's
very versed in the field and also he's
given a presentation last presentation
of the day so Dan RN's question is
besides zebra fish what are the most
common fish
species used in your
facility
right now in our facility we are working
just with SRA F we have also another
aquatic animals we we have Copus Lis and
few years ago we have also
aots right now I'm just working with
therapist but I used to work in a public
aquarium so I handle many many
species
okay the next question I guess it comes
from me I have seen a number of fish
facilities that have the the pump to the
tanks located in the same room where the
fish are housed when I asked
investigators about uh this possibly
being stressful to the fish the response
I get is that the fish get used to it in
some cases I've seen these bums and I
heard them they're quite loud do you
have have any thoughts on how to respond
to these investigators that say it's
okay to have those pumps that are loud
in the
rooms okay I think it's much better to
have your pumps outside of of your
facility in another in another room but
sometimes you don't have the chance to
to do that also the single rocks usually
has the the pump uh over the the system
so uh the the fish really get used to to
an ambient and this really important to
avoid the vibrations but the suddenly
ones if you have a constant vibration
usually the fish is going to to to
process like okay it's fine so they get
used to that and usually you don't have
any problems if you are going to have
suddenly noises maybe it's better to
have a a a low sound behind that so they
don't get so stressed so also it's much
better for for the staff having the the
pumps outside because the noise of the
pumps are really harmful and they are
not really fine for you so it depends of
what you have in your facility in our
case we have the pumps inside of the
facility so it has no we don't have any
problem about
that the next question comes from Jesse
Edington from the University of Alberta
do you have a food delivery system or
tool that is specific for the zebra fish
racks when feeding
powder sorry about that I I lost
when feeding powder
food when feeding powder food to the
small recirculation tanks there is often
a mess created from spilled food on the
lids of the tanks and this mess can then
spoil spoil if it builds
up
uh I don't know if you understand that
well the the question but I think you
were asking about the the tiny mess that
you have with the fries and with the
with the
lares uh if they get cloth with the
powder we we are using the the the
ceramic cron that is just a little
amount what we are using also to deliver
this this uh ceramicon is is a mess that
helps us to reduce the amount and give
in a bigger space so if you have problem
because the mess is getting Cloud maybe
you should change the the tank is much
better so just passing the all the water
with the fries from one tank to another
always put at the bottom of the new tank
uh some water so they don't get crushed
with the bottom of the tank usually with
don't have problems with that because
it's like a routine so we we know that
if we spend like 20 days with this tank
everything goes goes fine if we keep
like 25 we can have problems so it's
just to to figure out that your written
and check it but usually we don't have
problems about that because you are we
are using just a little amount of of
this
powder
the next question comes from Danielle or
Daniel wasu from University of Winnipeg
What factors contribute to egg binding
conditions in
medaka
sorry h i I never work with mea so I
can't ask about this question I'm so
sorry I just work with ER marine fish
and and the therapy so I I never use
medas immune facility sorry
next question is from caric but M nahan
from
tanas can
disease but healed zebra fish be used
for further research
purposes theist can be used for for
almost all the purpose for
research there are studies about brain
heart related with biomedical also with
pathology pathology of humans pathology
of fish uh many many kind of
applications is really easy also to to
generate the strin so you can find a
model for almost all the things right
now the the big issue for for therapist
I think is taking account for Toxicology
studies that will increase the the
number of facilities and the importance
of thees in the research s but I think
the the is really useful for for
research any kind of of
things okay the next question comes from
Adriana Pera unid academica the medicina
veterinaria and I'm going to trans
translate because the question is in
Spanish congratulations for your
presentation doctor I learned a an awful
lot
H
since I have only uh handle these
species uh simple pets and I have
focused on small
species I have found it it seems very
interesting
H the whole aspect of area of euthanasia
that you
mentioned since the industry the fishing
industry does an issue as far as wellbe
of the
animals the MS not sure what the MS
stands for is used in amphibians oh
methas sulphonate ms222 I think that's
what she means for eutanasia of fish is
used in amphibia
but I have never been able to find it in
Mexico why
have H why have they decided to
discontinue this I'm about to start a
doctorate degree at the University of
Alabama
Birmingham and I hope to meet you one of
these days thank you very
much
I don't know if I understand the the
question properly but I think she was
asking about three and they used to to
for eutanasia in our case we first of
all we
start intering the animals with
tri but uh we we went to to a conference
where thta Bargas was
and he present the new protocol by so
termic sock and we found out this this
protocol is much better because we don't
release any drugs to the to the media
and also for fish is really fast and
really secure we don't have any problems
with that that doesn't happen with
amphibians so in aerious in our case we
decide not to use Trine Asal protocol we
are are using doal delated so it's much
safer for for the animals and you don't
have any any kind of problems with that
uh I don't know how do do do you can
find uh Tri in Mexico but here in Spain
we don't have any problem and I think
Sigma ald has
it
well this conclude this presentation by
ju uh again thank you H ju for such an
interesting presentation and than I
would like to thank the audience also
for the great questions and for
participating in this event today's
webcast will be available for on demand
viewing through August
2015 you will receive an email from LA
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event well thanks again and we'll
see you next time
goodbye